John Cusack has played some of the most iconic
roles of all time.
From Say Anything to High Fidelity, Bullets
Over Broadway to Being John Malkovich, Cusack
has charmed audiences for decades.
But although the talented, versatile actor
has been in the business over 30 years, his
career isn't what it used to be.
Why?
Let's take a look back and see why John Cusack
hasn't graced our screens for a while.
He called Hollywood "a whorehouse"
In an interview with The Guardian about his
role in the Hollywood satire Map to the Stars,
John Cusack came clean about his views on
the strange world of Hollywood.
Cusack commented that the old ways of filmmaking
are gone and now everything revolves around
franchises and huge stars...which isn't really
all that off the mark.
As he puts it, "The culture just eats young
actors up and spits them out.
It's a hard thing to survive without finding
safe harbor."
It's easy to understand his seeming hesitation
to fight for stardom in an industry he's lost
trust in considering his views on Hollywood.
He went on to describe it by saying, "[Hollywood
is] a whorehouse and people go mad."
Writing films
Not content to be a just an actor, Cusack
has co-written a few of his most popular films.
He co-wrote the screenplays for High Fidelity
and Grosse Pointe Blank, proving that he knows
a few things about dark comedy and oddball
characters.
"Did I listen to pop music because I was miserable?
Or was I miserable because I listened to pop
music?"
More recently, he co-wrote the political film
War, Inc. as well as We Are Not Animals, which
is, fittingly, a film about an actor getting
tired of Hollywood.
Though it doesn't look like he has any new
screenplays in the works as of the making
of this video, he's still been writing quite
a bit.
The only difference is he's turned his writing
efforts to the political arena.
Politically active
John Cusack isn't your typical actor interested
in the political world.
When Visa, Mastercard, and Paypal all stopped
taking payments intended for Wikileaks in
2010, Cusack became a founding member of the
Freedom of the Press Foundation in response.
The Foundation's main goal is to protect the
privacy of the journalists willing to deal
with potentially dangerous subjects.
"It's an advocacy group just uh, try to protect
the rights of journalists to do their job.
Protect their sources."
Through crowdfunding, they help different
press organizations stay afloat regardless
of outside pressures.
Cusack has written many articles for the site
and is clearly passionate about the issue
of freedom of speech.
Cusack has also written over 20 articles for
the Huffington Post, and in 2014, he traveled
to Russia with Arundhati Roy and Daniel Ellsberg
to meet with Edward Snowden.
Roy and Cusack wrote a series of essays about
their conversations with Snowden which they
formed into the book Things That Can and Cannot
Be Said.
Cusack is still devoted to activism and it's
obvious he's not happy just resting on his
celebrity — he wants to make a real difference.
And with so much time spent in the political
arena, it's no wonder he doesn't light up
the marquee as much anymore.
Aging out of the rom-com
Cusack started out as a teenage heartthrob,
playing the sweet, slightly nerdy guy who'd
do anything for his girl.
"Gee, I'm real sorry your mom blew up Ricky."
But nobody can play the handsome leading man
forever.
Though Cusack often branched out to do less
mainstream work like Being John Malkovich
and Midnight in the Garden of Good and Evil,
he kept taking lead roles.
And those movies got worse and worse — at
least according to critics...and box office
receipts.
Sure, he's got High Fidelity, but he also
made Must Love Dogs, Serendipity, and America's
Sweethearts, and you didn't even realize those
clips were out of order.
And he definitely wasn't in American Beauty.
"American Beauty?
What's funny about that?"
"You were in that"
"No I wasn't!"
American Beauty?"
It seems that mainstream Hollywood wants to
put him in leading roles in dull action flicks
or rom-coms, whereas Cusack clearly wants
to go in a different direction, like the killer
roles he played in The Frozen Ground and The
Paperboy.
When Hollywood only wants to see you play
the same thing over and over again, it's no
wonder Cusack is a little hesitant to keep
taking on huge leads.
Straight to DVD
Cusack hasn't been in as many blockbusters
as he used to.
But that doesn't mean he's given up acting.
In fact, Cusack's been making tons of movies.
Between 2012 and 2016, he made a whopping
17 films.
The reason you might not be aware of that
insane productivity is that most of the films
wind up going straight to video-on-demand
or DVD.
And they tend to be...well, unimpressive,
like Reclaim or the fake-sounding Drive Hard.
Four of his films since 2014 got critics'
ratings below 5% on Rotten Tomatoes.
That's full-blown Nicolas Cage territory.
"I'm gonna try and kill the man!"
Just kidding.
Nic Cage is in a league of his own.
Critically ignored
That's not to say that John Cusack's recent
movies are all bad.
In 2015, he starred in Love & Mercy as an
older Brian Wilson — frontman for The Beach
Boys — dealing with mental illness and a
controlling manager.
The film received excellent reviews, with
many praising Cusack's fine work in particular.
But the film only made $12 million domestically,
and though there was some speculation about
a potential Oscar nomination, Cusack came
up short.
He wasn't nominated for a single award the
entire season, and the film itself was similarly
shut out.
Things to come
Though it may seem like Cusack's star has
dimmed, all it's really done is split into
a constellation of different projects.
John Cusack won't be fading into the background
any time soon.
His political writing and activism will surely
keep him busy in the next few years, and he's
already got another film lined up.
With more than 30 years in the acting business,
we're pretty sure he's got more than a few
more iconic parts up his sleeve.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!